we'll start with the lowest hanging
fruit which relates to the decision that
came last night from le'veon bell
reportedly choosing between the bills
the chiefs and the dolphins and then he
narrowed it to the chiefs and the
dolphins and frankly in all due respect
to the dolphins
if you're gonna narrow it to those two
teams
you're gonna take the chiefs you're
gonna you're gonna ride with the
champions you're gonna go with the
opportunity to play deep into january
pump up your resume and hit the market
next year because it's a one-year deal
as everyone expected it to be it allows
him to become a free agent after the
season and
this is a a win-win right if bell still
has it peter this is a win-win for him
and for a team that could use a
compliment to rookie clyde edwards
well the reason why this pairing works
so well is that andy reed wants to throw
the ball to the running backs out of the
backfield he wants to design plays
for these great wheel routes
uh you saw what he did with kareem hunt
right away in 2017 in new england he
designed a play with
kareem hunt on dante hightower and it
went for 70 plus yards and a touchdown
that is what andy reid loves to do he
loves to not only have his receivers to
be threats in the intermediate part of
the field but also his running backs
that's where i think le'veon bell was
swayed and that's why the chiefs really
wanted him i'm sure the money is not
that much
for kansas city and you know i also
think everybody was
really excited about clyde edwards
hilaire at the beginning of the year and
rightfully so
he's an excellent player and i think
he's going to have a great career
but
when you
focus so much on one player in one
running back and yeah they they have
other backs in their stable
but
you know le'veon bell is going to give
them the opportunity to have a we think
but we don't know a premiere back out of
the backfield mike the reason why we
don't know
is that le'veon bell sat out 2018
he was mediocre the last year and a
third
uh with the jets so i mean think about
it mike it's been three years
since le'veon bell has been great
so is he still great he'll tell you he
is
the chiefs will tell you we think he is
but we simply do not know we just don't
know
yeah and you look at how it tails off on
the chart from the football perspective
twitter account the the gold dots with
the black rim are his performances with
the steelers and then the cluster at the
right where it all drops off that's what
happened with the jets now last year he
still had
a decent season by running back
standards 1200 plus yards from scrimmage
but it wasn't le'veon bell standards it
wasn't 13.5 million a year with the
first two years and 27 million
guaranteed let me spin back to clyde
edwards elaire because when they drafted
him
the thought was this year it would be
damian williams and clyde edward zelaire
sharing the load that's what brett veach
the gm of the team told me just days
after the draft this isn't we're making
clyde edwards elaire the number one guy
and damien just gets pushed aside damian
williams played really well in the super
bowl and helped contribute significantly
to the victory but then williams opts
out over the pandemic
and we all just kind of say oh well it's
clyde edwards well you know what they
made a play for adrian peterson which
tells you they've been thinking about
this
for a while and last year they made a
play for le'veon bell when the jets were
talking to teams about trading and bell
said so it was the packers it was the
chiefs it was the texans it was the
steelers and there was one more that i
keep forgetting but there were teams
that were interested in him last year he
just wasn't interested
in revising the contract that paid him
27 million fully guaranteed and you look
at edwards elaire's performance he blew
us away with 138 yards rushing in week
one since then 70 total yards from
scrimmage against the chargers 64 yards
rushing against the ravens he added 70
receiving so that had him at 134 from
scrimmage he had 91 yards from scrimmage
in the win over the patriots and then
most recently 40 yards rushing 40 yards
receiving so he has not been tearing it
up the way that maybe we thought he was
going to right out of the gates and they
could use the help and a great point
chris made yesterday when we were
talking about what le'veon bell can do
if you put him in the backfield and you
run the ball and run the ball and run
the ball
that is going to get the defense to
react and maybe they sneak another
linebacker on the field to stop him as a
runner well once you get them in that
matchup you split him to the slot and
you let him go 70 yards against that
linebacker for a touchdown and that's
where le'veon bell becomes that mismatch
if you react to what he can do as a
running back he'll kill you as a
receiver
yeah and i think look no one's
criticizing clyde edwards hilaire he's
on pace for a
whatever almost 1100 yard rushing season
you know that's good
but i think
you know
i remember when i left kansas city camp
in august
i just told everybody take clyde edward
solaire
you know as you're running back and
again look if you took them over
christian mccaffrey and saquon barkley
you're a genius
but
i in in general in general
i really did think especially in the
running game he was going to have given
the chiefs more
and especially after the first game of
the season but look this is classic andy
reid you know what he does
he basically overloads his stable
because he knows he understands that in
week 11
clyde edwards hilaire is going to get a
turf toe or a you know a strained calf
or something like that you know very
very rarely do your finely tuned
athletes
uh like edward hilaire is very rarely do
they
go through a 16 game regular season
without something happening to make them
less than a hundred percent and look
you know what
you know the one thing that le'veon bell
has done in the last year and a half is
pretty much conserve himself you know he
he's not had a heavy workload so to me
this just this is absolutely what andy
reid does every single year it's like a
a reed belichick move let's take
an undervalued penny stock
and let's let's let him grow
you know in our portfolio and that's
what i think le'veon bell is going to do
and they tried that last year with
lesean mccoy when he fell into the
chief's lap he was cut labor day weekend
by the bills somewhat surprisingly mccoy
really didn't do all that much and by
the time we got to the end of the season
he wasn't even active for some of the
most important postseason games so we'll
see what le'veon bell has the chiefs
will find out what le'veon bell has but
what he definitely has is a team that
wants him and it was never really all
that clear that the jets wanted him mike
mckagne did he paid too much adam gase
knew he paid too much mcagne frankly got
grifted by someone in bell's camp that
made
mccagnan believe the ravens were at the
table for the same amount and they never
were and it never got that relationship
off to a good start so no longer a jet
now a chief november 1 he gets to play
the jets who handed
le'veon bell to the open market and he
lands in kansas city
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports